with the 20th anniversary of september
11th comes a flood of memories and
emotions about the terror attacks that
took nearly 3 000 lives elise preston
spoke with one of the widows of a new
york city firefighter
of course a hero but first a husband and
father
one of the things i miss the most is
just laying in bed with my head on his
shoulder just talking away and van
hine's husband was a new york city
firefighter one of the 343 fdny
responders who died in the attack on the
world trade center now when i look at
these names
i i know they're family members for
bruce van hine being a firefighter was a
childhood dream squad 41 lost everyone
on duty that day they lost all six
firefighters they went into building two
and got pretty high up started to bring
civilians down
and then they were killed in the
collapse
when was the last time you spoke to
bruce the last time i saw bruce was
sunday september 9th he said i'm um i'm
blessed and i said why
he said because i'm married to miss anne
now the grandmother of three volunteers
at the 911 tribute museum giving more
than 500 tours where bruce died a hero
but the one day she never visits the
site is the september 11th anniversary i
don't know that i can take on the
collective grief of 3 000 people
20 years ago joan master polo lived just
a block west of the towers she watched
the attacks from her office window i saw
both towers get struck by the planes
i was never able to make it back home as
a volunteer for the tribute museum she
shares stories of both the horrors and
humanity of the day we had over 500
thousand people come here after nine
eleven with only one objective
they wanted to help that support from
both loved ones and strangers has helped
van hine carry on as she honors her
husband's memory and makes sure we never
forget elise preston cbs news new york
8 news now has coverage all week long to
commemorate 20 years since 9 11. the
i-team airing stories at 6 pm each night
and we'll also have a special newscast
saturday at 6 30.